il est
cassé j'étais tranquille j'étais peénard
à cou et au flippur le type est entré
dans le bar a commandé un jambon beur
s'est approché de moi il m'a regardé
comme çaas des bottes mon pote elle me
botte je paris que c'est santiag vient
faire un tour dans le terrain vague je
vais t'apprendre un je à grand coup de
chaîne de vélo je te fais tes bottes à
la baston moi je laisse
béton il m'a filé une beigne j'ai filé
une tornole m'a filé une châigne je lui
ai filé mes
grolles j'étais tranquille j'étais
peinard à cou au comptoir le type est
entré dans le bar à commandé un café
noir puis il m'a tapé sur l'épaule et ma
regarde d' a drôle un blouson Meon il
est pas bidon moi je me les gel sur mon
scooter avec flasheray un vrai rockur
viens faire un tour dans la ruelle je te
montrerai mon opinelle et je te
chouravrai ton blouson moi je dit laiss
Béon il m'a filé une beigne j'ai filé un
marron m filé une châigne j'ai filé mon
blouson j'étais tranquille j'étais
peinard je réparais ma mobylette le type
pas surgit sur le boulevard sur sa
grosse moto super chouette s'est arrêté
le long du trottoir et ma regarde des
dernières bê tu as le même blue jean que
James tuarrê ta fr que c'est un vrai les
est carrément pas crignos viens faire un
tour derrière l'église histoire que je
te dévalise un grand coup de ceinturon
moi j laiss
béton il m'a filé une beigne j'ai filé
une mandale m'a filé une chatigne j'ai
filé mon
FAL la morale de cette pauvre histoire
c'est quand tu es tranquille il les
peinards faut pas trop traîner dans les
bars à moins d'être fringué en poard
quand à la fin d'une chanson tu te
retrouves à poil sans tes bottes faut
avoir de l'imagination pour trouver une
chute
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rigolote